Also what we did was we looked at different types of filtering mechanisms.
So here I want to be able to take a box filter.
In this one I'm showing a 21 by 21 box filter with uniform values and
we can apply that to smoothing of an image.
If you look at this part of the image here.
And you sense, basically, you see a flat, gray kernel.
And, if you look at it in a height map that we've looked at it basically it's
got a fixed value just like this.
And that basically is now our average or a box filter.
Let's look at how we would apply a box filter to an original image like this,
the pepper's image.
Again, it's the flat kernel.
When applied you get a blurry image.
This is a 21 by 21 kernel.
The linear combination of the weights here with the linear,
with the constant values of the box here, result in a rather blurry image.
Notice again, this is a flat kernel or a box filter.